[Music]
time now for morning rounds are look at
the medical news of the week beginning
with the latest news for those trying to
quit smoking the CDC released a report
this week that looks at the different
methods American smokers used to kick
the habit study analyzed results from a
survey that started in 2014 and ended
last year it included nearly 16,000
current smokers who tried quitting in
the previous three months seventy-four
percent reported they used multiple
methods to quit CBS News chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook and CBS
News contributor dr. Tara narula are
here to discuss harlots what were the
most popular methods that they used so
quitting can be such a challenge and
really overwhelming when you start to
think how do I go about tackling this
and so it's not surprising that people
used multiple strategies you know in
general about two-thirds of smokers want
to quit 50% try over the course of a
year only four to seven percent actually
are successful in a year so not great in
this survey when they looked at the most
popular strategies that ended up being
quitting cold turkey so stopping
cigarettes all at once or cutting back
slowly and gradually less popular
methods e-cigarettes and I was surprised
to see how not frequent medications and
counseling were used in the survey dr.
LaPook thirty-five percent of those
surveyed used e-cigarettes how do those
compare with other more traditional
methods and about twenty-five percent at
the end of the day ended up continuing
to use some form of e-cigarettes to help
them another quarter use a nicotine
based product like gum or a patch about
fifteen percent talk to their doctors
are there other clinicians to four
strategies and only about twelve percent
tower was alluding as twelve percent
used in fda-approved medication when you
look at the six-month success level
which I just looked up at the CDC help
me with this fourteen percent success
rate with placebo and it's about twice
thats anywhere from twenty to thirty
percent using the various different
methods don't be discouraged though
whenever you see all these different
methods it means one doesn't work but
here's a fact that just blew me away if
you are smoking but you stop smoking
before you're forty you reduce smoking
associated deaths by ninety percent Wow
ninety that's the line in the sand
many years old yeah all right even after
that this the study talked about what
was used but but not always successful
so I mean as a doctor what how do you
come up with a strategy here i have to
say Anthony you know one of the most
rewarding things is when you sit across
from your patient and they say I have
quit smoking because you know they've
altered the trajectory of the rest of
their life and as a health care provider
we can really make a difference evidence
has shown just by talking to patients
five to ten minutes even at visits about
smoking cessation talking to patients
about a quit plan setting a quick date
giving them support and referrals to
things like 800 quit lines to counseling
groups talking about medications like
nicotine patches zyban chantix and then
one of the most compelling things is the
CDC has a program called the tips
campaign where they actually basically
humanize this issue by showing and
telling real-life stories of people who
are former smokers you see visually how
they are and how it's affected them you
hear how it's affected them and their
family and according to the CDC that
really / smokers makes more of an impact
seeing those stories and hearing those
stories than just hearing a doctor tell
them you know it can cause cancer and
heart disease and also making it safe to
tell the truth so if they failed in
their own mind oh my god I'm still
smoking don't lie to your doctor tell
them the truth and you're working on
this together it's a tough it's one of
the toughest things in the world to do
stop silly behavior and medication are
the best proven strategies both so many
people want to quit so help them quit
alright our next topic allergy season
this year spring started much earlier in
many parts of the country the red parts
of this map show the plant blooming
activity of those areas but how ready
are people with seasonal allergies for
that we turn to our doctors who looked
at a 2015 survey by the Asthma and
Allergy Foundation of America and the
pharmaceutical company mark okay so John
preventative measures are people taking
those when they know allergy season is
upon them you know they are not more
than three-quarters of people wait until
the symptoms are upon them more than
half of them don't even know what the
prescription options are and and less
than half know what the triggers are or
really had to do management and I spoke
to an allergist about this Jess
yesterday it's really important to start
a lot of these medications beforehand if
you're having allergy shots or even
doing the new under the tongue method of
giving sort of an allergy shot like
prevention has to be done months in
advance and with antihistamines some of
these drops has to be done days or even
a couple of weeks beforehand so it's
important to not wait until it sneaks up
on you I saw this map for this season
where it's a little bit of an earlier
season along in much of the country
Terrill one of the most common allergies
pollen related a pollen what are some of
the recommendations for dealing with
that so check the pollen levels you can
see it on your weather forecast go to
the National allergy Bureau website stay
indoors at the peak times 5 to 10 a.m.
close your windows don't use window fans
use air conditioning wash your clothes
wash your hair and your body at the end
of the day and your sheets to get all
those allergens off and wear sunglasses
and a hat Wow washing the hair so
important because otherwise it's just
sprinkling down and you won't get inside
frosting your head stay in a sealed room
okay hermetically sealed finally
harvesting water researchers at MIT and
the University of California Berkeley
created a device that pulls moisture
from the air using only the power of the
Sun when tested in humidity conditions
similar to areas in North Africa it made
almost three liters of water in a day
the water harvester is still a prototype
but researchers say it could eventually
help bring water to the hundreds of
millions of people who suffer through
droughts each year that's a huge
development technology it's amazing and
they use the power of the Sun to release
the water from this material that
they've created that dense that first
sucks up the water it's a prototype now
very small amounts of water but the
thought is over the years if you scale
it up be amazing and access to water
remains a major problem across the globe
this could be the only gonna be a singer
to dr. Stein LaPook and Tara narula
great to see you as always